tercera noche de la convención nacional
demócrata en la que escucharemos a
kamala harris la candidata a la
vicepresidencia en las elecciones de
noviembre y al ex mandatario barack
obama entre otros
anoche los demócratas oficializaron la
candidatura de joe biden para enfrentar
a donald trump en las presidenciales
tenemos reporte desde washington
la unión europea- desconoció las
elecciones en belarús que le dieron la
victoria a alexander lukashenko quien
lleva 26 años en el poder los líderes
del bloque se reunieron este miércoles
en una cumbre virtual extraordinaria
para evaluar la situación tras los
comicios y las posteriores protestas y
así definir medidas que incluyen
sanciones a sus líderes
definida la gran final de la liga de
campeones el bayern munich obtuvo su
boleto al superar 3 por 0 al lyon el
equipo alemán fue superior en la
semifinal y ahora buscará el campeonato
frente a otro equipo francés el psg de
mba pe y neymar tenemos reporte también
de nuestra enviada especial
hola cómo están buenas noches en américa
latina' y a todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
talan austria sean bienvenidos estamos a
menos de una hora para que comience el
gran evento del día en la tercera noche
de la convención nacional demócrata en
la que veremos a miembros prominentes de
este partido movilizar el apoyo para joe
biden es que ayer se confirmó ya como el
candidato a la presidencia de eeuu por
parte de los demócratas
esta vez hablarán a favor de bailén
figuras como barack obama el primer
presidente afro de esta nación
hillary clinton la primera mujer
demócrata nominada para presidenta o
kamala harris la primera candidata
afroamericana en una fórmula
presidencial la jornada estará centrada
desde luego en el racismo sistémico los
derechos de las mujeres el debate por el
porte de armas y la protección para los
soñadores los dreamers nuestra
corresponsal en washington diana a
castella nos dio más detalles previo a
esta tercera noche de la convención
nacional demócrata
pues básicamente se espera que esta
noche a diferencia de los dos días
anteriores que vimos el primero en donde
el tema principal fue la unidad ayer el
liderazgo y el tema serán la inmigración
y un discurso más de inclusión hacia las
minorías no solamente los afroamericanos
sino también los inmigrantes que viven
en los eeuu el discurso central será de
la candidata a la vicepresidencia
kamala harris pero también se espera que
el ex presidente barack obama sea muy
firme y más fuerte en el tono de su
discurso haciendo un listado de digamos
lo que consideran los demócratas lo que
han sido un fracaso de las políticas del
presidente de nación para hacer frente a
la pandemia también se esperan vídeos
hay que recordar que esta convención es
virtual y los demócratas grabaron más de
mil vídeos para poder tener estos cuatro
días de transmisión así que veremos más
vídeos de ciudadanos que muestran sus
problemáticas y lo que esperan de byd en
si llega a ser presidente así que será
una noche en donde veremos a líderes y
personajes tradicionales del partido
demócrata
esta noche esperen nuestro tercer
especial informativo sobre la convención
demócrata en eeuu a partir de las 8 de
la noche ahora bogotá quito lima y
ciudad de méjico escucharemos y
analizaremos los discursos que tendrán
lugar desde el día del martes hasta el
jueves 20 de agosto desde el lunes que
comenzó la convención nacional demócrata
nos vamos a brasil donde el
vicepresidente negó que la selva
amazónica esté en llamas sin embargo los
incendios aumentaron un 28% en julio
frente al mismo mes de 2010 y 9 pues se
registraron al menos 6 mil 800 focos el
instituto nacional de investigación
espacial de brasil dijo que detectó más
de 3100 incendios en las dos primeras
semanas de agosto esto es cinco veces
más que en el mismo periodo del año
pasado el gobierno anunció una campaña
para ayudar a los habitantes de la zona
a tomar conciencia sobre la quema
agrícola
en otros temas la unión europea no
reconoció el resultado de las elecciones
presidenciales del 9 de agosto en
belarús alegando que se produjo fraude
electoral los líderes europeos acordaron
imponer sanciones a los responsables de
la violencia contra los manifestantes
mientras que el presidente alexander
lukashenko reforzó las fronteras veamos
este informe de álvaro cordero
la unión europea rechazó los resultados
de las elecciones de belarús del pasado
9 de agosto
los líderes europeos aseguraron que los
comicios no fueron libres en el país y
condenaron la violencia policial
ejercida contra los manifestantes
opositores no hay duda de que hubo
violaciones masivas de las reglas de las
elecciones las elecciones no fueron
libres ni justas y es por eso que el
resultado de los comicios no puede ser
reconocido la presión aumenta sobre ming
que desde el 9 de agosto atraviesa
jornadas de huelga en general contra el
gobierno algo que ha hecho que las
detenciones se multipliquen en belarús y
que la candidata opositora es vendan
ática no es que haya se haya visto
obligada a salir del país desde su
exilio en lituania llamó para elecciones
bajo supervisión internacional en esta
ocasión el señor lukashenko ha perdido
toda la legitimidad a los ojos de
nuestra nación y del mundo
ante la situación lukashenko anunció que
reforzaría militarmente las fronteras
del país y que prestaría especial
atención a las fuerzas de la otan
[Aplausos]
si alguien piensa que el poder está
fallando y tambaleándose está equivocado
ese poder tiene algo
en quien confiar así que no vacilaremos
seguiremos con nuestro camino como es
debido
sobre los serbios o los que hoy están
conspirando contra nosotros recibirán un
serio rechazo al escritorio para los
estudios de doctor alexander lukashenko
lleva en el poder en belarús desde 1994
y aunque la oposición ha conseguido
desafiar su poder las autoridades
electorales anunciaron que lukashenko
tomará juramento dentro de dos meses
por primera vez en la historia la
universidad nacional autónoma de méxico
fue sede del examen de admisión para
nivel licenciatura esto debido a las
medidas que se implementaron por la
crisis sanitaria del coronavirus mario'
carbonell nuestro corresponsal tiene el
reporte desde este instituto en la
capital mexicana más de 2.200 aspirantes
a entrar a la universidad nacional
autonoma de mexico a cursar una de las
129 carreras pasan el examen aquí en el
estadio universitario
ezequiel es uno de los últimos alumnos
en ingresar ezequiel suerte a qué
carrera quieres entrar ecología muy bien
en cuánto tiempo te preparaste para este
examen un año aproximadamente un año que
es fuera de la unam cuáles son tus
expectativas pues expectativas de tener
la mejor educación que pueda para
obtener una mejor carrera por lo que si
me entienden
y la biblioteca
la unam está entre las 100 mejores
universidades de todo el mundo de
acuerdo con el bóer world university
rankings en mexico es la casa de
estudios mejor evaluada y es la segunda
a nivel américa latina después de la de
buenos aires
[Música]
quiero entrar a la
carrera de médico cirujano y me estuve
preparando alrededor de 11 mis
en las series alternas de la ciudad el
día de hoy y mañana serán 82 mil los
concursantes y del 25 al 29 de agosto
serán evaluados también aspirantes en
michoacán yucatán y guanajuato el 21 de
septiembre recibirán sus resultados y
sabrán si tienen un lugar en la máxima
casa de estudios
[Música]
ahora vamos con información del
coronavirus que les destacamos hoy
jueves 19 de agosto
españa superó los 3000 casos diarios de
kobe 19 por primera vez desde mayo las
autoridades registraron en 24 horas su
mayor cifra de contagios confirmados
desde el levantamiento del estado de
alarma lo cual situó la cifra total en
españa' en 370 mil 867
francia impone el uso obligatorio de
cubrebocas en la gran mayoría de los
lugares de trabajo a partir del primero
de septiembre para evitar el contagio
del cob y 19 en las empresas el gobierno
de manuel macro no emitió que el uso de
las mascarillas hará sistemático en
todos los espacios cerrados y
compartidos de las compañías
líbano sufre un repunte de casos de
coronavirus tras las explosiones que el
4 de agosto sacudieron el puerto de
beirut el traslado de gran cantidad de
los heridos en las explosiones a
hospitales sin medidas preventivas
habría aumentado los contagios por lo
que la nación comenzará este viernes un
confinamiento que durará al menos dos
semanas
en otros temas el autoproclamado jefe
del golpe militar de malí dijo que el
país no podía soportar más errores e
informó que se celebrarán elecciones en
un plazo razonable la sublevación
apoyada en las calles por miles de
ciudadanos ha recibido la unánime
condena internacional vamos a este
informe de marina sardiña
mal y despertó con la dimisión forzada
de su presidente e ibragim bubacar keita
la disolución de la asamblea nacional
no deseo que se derrame sangre para
mantenerme en el poder muy bien después
del golpe de estado orquestado por el
ejército maliense durante el martes y el
arresto del mandatario en el poder desde
2013 los militares bajo el
autodenominado comité nacional para la
salvación del pueblo prometieron
realizar elecciones en un tiempo
razonable y actuar para evitar más caos
anarquía e inseguridad
[Música]
malienses no nos interesa el poder pero
si la estabilidad del país lo que nos
permitirá organizar en un plazo
razonable elecciones generales que le
permitan a mali dotarse de instituciones
fuertes capaces de gestionar nuestra
vida cotidiana y restablecer la
confianza entre el gobierno y el pueblo
quien fue visto como una figura de
unidad en un país fracturado por la
violencia yihadista keita fue incapaz de
cumplir su promesa de unir a la nación y
solventar sus crisis en las calles de
bamako cientos de ciudadanos celebraron
su caída del poder no no nos esperábamos
esto en absoluto fue una sorpresa pero
en cualquier caso la población había
abandonado al presidente necesitábamos
que los militares intervinieron para
poner fin a lo que estaba pasando ante
el temor de que la renuncia del
mandatario pueda desestabilizar toda la
región del sahel en áfrica occidental la
comunidad internacional condenó el acto
y la unión africana suspendió la
membresía de malí vamos con información
deportiva y es que ya sabemos la final
de la liga de campeones- considerado por
la competencia de fútbol a nivel club es
más relevante del mundo el bayern múnich
ganó 3 por 0 a lyon y se enfrentará al
parís saint germain en la gran final que
se disputará el domingo 23 de agosto en
el estadio da luz de lisboa el equipo
alemán clasifica así a su undécima final
de esta liga nuestra enviada especial a
este evento en portugal natalia ruiz
tiene más detalles
la final de la liga de campeones será
franco alemana el bayern munich que
consiguió su pase a la final tras vencer
al olympique lyonnais tres goles por 0
en la noche de este miércoles aquí en
lisboa el bayern munich es
definitivamente uno de los equipos más
contundentes de esta copa algunas caras
largas aquí en el lisboa por parte de
lucio hinchas franceses tras la derrota
de el olympique lyonnais y sin embargo
con los hinchas que pudimos hablar ellos
dijeron estar muy orgullosos de lo
conseguido por su equipo una sorpresa en
realidad que lograran llegar hasta él a
estas alturas de la competencia
semifinales tras vencer a dos grandes de
europa por un parte por una parte a la
juventus de turín en octavos y al
manchester city en cuartos de final
ahora el bayern munich pues se disputará
esta gran final el domingo en el estadio
de la luz aquí en la lisboa ante el
parís son rama el bayern que buscará su
sexta corona europea mientras que el
parís su primera
y cambiamos la cinta para finalizar y es
que tras el impacto económico que deja
el coronavirus en italia el sector
cultural se está reinventando este
verano la industria cinematográfica está
dando un nuevo impulso a los antiguos
autos cines que todos consideraban
obsoletos nuestro equipo en italia nos
tiene en la historia
otro atasco esta tarde en roma pero esta
vez por una buena razón
estos cinéfilos van a disfrutar de una
proyección al aire libre un autocine que
permite una proyección segura con cada
uno en su propio coche el
distanciamiento social está garantizado
en ese vuelo enfado que no podemos ir a
los cines de interior esta es una gran
alternativa en un divertido
continuaré nos da la impresión de tener
una vida normal como antes pero seguimos
estando a salvo
con 500 cupos disponibles repartidos en
60.000 metros cuadrados es el mayor
autocine en europa que también ama la
gente necesita ir al cine aquí en sus
autos no tienen que llevar una máscara
pueden oír claramente y disfrutar de la
protección sin preocuparse podría ser el
futuro del cine una vez que la noche ha
caído y que las radios se han
sincronizado para obtener la banda
sonora el espectáculo comienza
para algunos el autocine es algo nuevo
pero para otros es regresar al pasado un
visado o andar odio harán que 8 me
recuerda a mi niñez y todo está más o
menos igual viajar en el tiempo así es
super periodo
ver la chamberga del carnaval es un
regalo encantador porque nos permite
salir y pasar una agradable velada con
los amigos damos 1 por 10 euros por
vehículo los aficionados al cine pueden
seguir disfrutando de la pantalla grande
hasta que los cines vuelvan a abrir
completamente en italia
pues como de película así finalizamos
muchas gracias por su compañía los
invitamos a seguir con nosotros en
france24 ya que se cuide cuídese mucho
del cob y thyssen
[Música]